E aí
[Música]
Oi e esse aqui é João Gil Meu filho e a
gente vai fazer um set musical para
vocês
é a primeira música que a gente vai
tocar é uma música de Gilberto Gil e o
ali Salomão e
[Música]
E aí
o Tom escrever o Ferreiro Rosa capitão
da capitania da minha cabeça mandarina
alforria para o meu coração
E ai ai minhas espadas Fábio só mato
varre a felicidade do negro é uma
felicidade guerreira mar com tomar aqui
espada espalham só meu Quilombo
Encantado ep 1
o licor moleque o sapateado do povo do
mestre da escola de samba de ladeira dia
deitado estava aguentando estopim no
podo loubotin Tem cada intervalo da
guerra sem fim eu canto eu canto eu
canto eu canto eu canto eu canto assim a
felicidade do negro é uma felicidade
guerreira a felicidade foi do nenhuma
felicidade vida a felicidade do negro é
uma felicidade guerreira
o Brasil meu Brasil brasileiro meu
grande terreiro meu berço e Nação Zumbi
protetor adianta padroeiro mandar eu
forrei ia para o meu coração e
[Música]
E aí
[Aplausos]
[Música]
e agora a gente vai fazer uma música do
nosso querido Chico César
é obrigado a minha mãe solteira e tem
que fazer todo dia além da cadeira a
minha mãe minha mãe solteira e tenho que
fazer mamadeira
e todo dia além de trabalhar como
empacotadeira na Casas Bahia uma África
tempo
eu queria fazer além da mamãe brincar
solteira e tenho que fazer além de
trabalhar como empacotadeira as Casas
Bahia quando lama sai de casa seus
filhos solando usam rolo maior de mama
tem calo nos pés mama precisa de paz
mama não quer brincar mais filhinho dá
um tempo é tão
o tempo eo ritmo de vida de mama África
a minha mãe minha mãe solteira e tenho
que fazer mamadeira todo além das
barriga e
é solteira e tem que fazer para madeira
tudo na paz
[Música]
E aí
e deve ser legal você é legal você é
legal deve ser legal né
é muito bom agora a gente vai fazer uma
música do grupo maravilhoso tincoãs da
Bahia cachoeira cachoeira
E aí
[Música]
Ah tá então tá bom então
E hoje é
E aí
a agir
a Sara vai usar deixa agir agir AG
[Música]
a letra gira gira gira
oi oi
E aí
[Música]
Que dia é
E aí
[Música]
e o Gira deixa a gira girar
E aí
[Aplausos]
[Música]
E aí
eu tava te implorando e para fechar esse
sete eu queria agora vamos agora cantar
uma música de uma compositora negra
brasileira linda forte moderna
e o AD Luna agradecer agradecer
compositores mesmo pois é e fechar esse
7 com uma música de uma mulher negra é
Power 1
E aí o ma Guarda tá aí para te procurar
[Música]
mas cadê você cadê você as pessoas muito
meu coração sente encontrado por pedir a
outra fala quem é
Ah então tá falando para mim uma
resposta eu não tava com nenhuma
resposta eu nunca volta para nenhuma
resposta não tá falando para mim uma
resposta eu não tava indo para nenhuma
resposta eu não tava falando para mim
não responde não dá nada para ninguém
uma resposta para me livrar para me
afastar de dormir pára-raio perto a
saber abre partilhe pára-raio Pet Branca
[Música]
patchuli vi
vou sair para te procurar você as
pessoas e
[Música]
me dá uma resposta eu não tava falando
para mim uma resposta eu não tava dando
para mim uma resposta não tá falta para
nenhuma resposta não tava falando não tá
falando para mim
[Música]
o bar
um para-raio Facebook passo aprender a
vitamina batida baralho.net Branca
acabei abre caminho para raio-x
[Música]
E aí
ir para a página para o amor
[Música]
E aí
bom obrigada gente muito obrigada pelo
convite excitex lançador é maravilhoso
aparador Muito obrigada mesmo Espero que
vocês tenham gostado das músicas eu
escolhi músicas com essa temática negra
brasileira porque é isso viu a cultura
brasileira viva a música brasileira vivo
os negros do Brasil viva a mulher negra
E aí